this is really good yeah it's actually
really good which is kind of like like
I'm questioning everything about ice
cream is the perfect dessert for summer
because it can be dressed down it can be
dressed up you get crazy toppings like
literally everything you could want you
can do with ice cream a variety of
stories we'll just like kind of like
drawing a bunch of random topping it's
like really cool to like try new things
with it because it's such a old standard
not a family glass Guiness yep I don't
hate it it's like a root beer float but
for people who drink Guinness is a stout
which has like chocolate and coffee in
it so you already kinda like a natural
it makes sense this is the stuff you
sell at your house parties in college
oh yeah no Sun and we have beer floats
because it's super hot outside - he
needs and downloads in hot shoes
it's another brown liquid let's go
sticky damn it's butterscotch ooh that's
like a melted butterscotch candy yeah
like grandma's house it's very salty too
salty
yeah I taste salty at me I'm into this
salty savory
[Music]
no see now I taste it but with the ice
cream with ice you know when you don't
know what it is you have no idea it's
like bad you like it if somebody gives
me a soy sauce and then all ice cream
okay I'm gonna tell you I think there's
you don't know anything
okay ready three two one olive oil it
tastes like banana
it's like Irby it's like this could be
an Italian treat like that's good see my
general assumption of life is that olive
oil makes everything better
I feel like this is just kind of neutral
though this is definitely hot I love
spicy food so long after the teeth yeah
here we go
tastes like hot wings like dessert
tastes like corn that's really good I
cannot handle spice at all but because
it has the milk aspect with it like
immediately kosher tongue and you just
get like the happy feeling of spice and
not the like painful I wish that I was
in a pool right now spice fiance is all
like I got hot sauce in my bag you got
hot sauce in our ice cream you know this
way I think at the end of the day we
learned that everything goes well with
ice thing I might be open to trying
other things now I would not be
surprised if one of these broke out and
became the next big thing like olive oil
or the the beer beer I heard the beer
one could be ahead I could yeah maybe we
should start a business I want to do
this to my friends on the trip I'm so
bad I gotta get that soy sauce on there
and everyone's gonna eat it and be like
this is so good I thought was I'm gonna
be like soy sauce and they're gonna blow
their minds
[Applause]
[Music]